[Music]
hello and welcome back to the rug - mm
my name is caleb envy as always i will
be your driver on this journey recently
I just made national master and that's
what the last class was about when
addressing speculation the road to 2000
is staying the road to 2000
I can't guarantee I can get you guys to
2,200 just got there myself so unless
you think you've got that special
x-factor that that you need to get to
2200 the road ends at 2000 for the
moment so with that out of the way let's
talk about the topic for tonight so one
of the most important events in the
chess world is going on right now and
actually it's about to conclude tomorrow
is the final round of the one and only
feed a World Cup and of course the
finalists in the feed a World Cup
guarantee themselves a spot in the
candidates match for the next World
Championship cycle so these two players
ding Lauren and Timur Raj both are
actually in the finals so they are both
guaranteed a place in that candidates
tournament and of course the winner of
the winner of the candidates goes on to
challenge Magnus for the world title in
the mesh so this is huge for a number of
reasons
ding Lauren was likely going to be the
person to qualify by rating for the
candidates but now that he's qualified
through the World Cup that reading slot
is moving down to the next highest rated
player and it's looking like that might
be Geary but it still remains to be seen
how the ratings shake out I think they
take an average rating so it's unclear
but ok this tournaments not over yet
actually 3 of the 4 standard games in
the final match have been played and
right now all stands level between ding
Lauren and to Mirage buff and so why
don't we take a look at a couple of
those games and then if you guys are
interested the final round is actually
tomorrow if you want to check that out I
highly recommend it but okay this was
round 2 I believe of the final between
ding Lauren and team arisia buff ding
Lauren started off with c4
the English opening black responded
night of six we saw Knight c3 e six this
is a very flexible way of playing from
black it doesn't really reveal to white
what black wants to do maybe he wants to
play d5 and play you know a more normal
Queens gambit declined structure he
could also play something like c5 and go
for Benoni style positions it's kind of
unclear but then with White's next move
he really makes the decision on what
type of game it's going to be white
plays d4 this move of course eyeing this
d5 square even more black could still
play d5 this is an opening line but
black chose instead to play c5 and what
does this allow for white here there's a
specific move that looks pretty natural
for white to kind of shake loose some of
the black pieces we're really the only
black piece that's developed any ideas
yeah d5 when your opponent hasn't really
a plate to control the center sometimes
this move is is playable this a five
move attacking this Knight and actually
simply forcing it to go back to g8 so
why would black play like this
any ideas like willingly developed his
knight allowed white to push forward and
forces Knight back to its starting
square what does black gain from doing
this
yeah so that's a that's a great point as
we're starting out you know we're always
told it's good to control the center you
know put your pawns in the center to
control it but the farther up a board
upon gets the more weak it actually
becomes the more vulnerable to attack it
becomes just because it's simply closer
to your opponent's pieces and further
away from your own so black is trying to
say that white has over extended with E
5 and black is actually going to play
against this pawn and that's how he's
going to try to find some activity in
this game and so we'll see that happen
here white plays Knight f3 a natural
developing move defending this pawn and
after Knight c6 white already commits to
d4 and so this is actually doing a lot
and this is actually a pawn sacrifice
from white so white has pushed this pawn
very far up the board and because of
that this pawn is slightly weak and by
playing d4 why it is already jettisoning
this pawn he's giving it away and he's
saying it was worth giving the pawn away
because you had to waste time with your
knight and so this is kind of the
character of the game we see the pawn
sacrifice is played out with C takes d4
Knight takes d4 removing the defender of
this pawn Knight takes e5 is played and
now white plays Knight d b5 so we kind
of see the point of White's play black
has one piece developed but it's kind of
on a loose undefended square this Knight
has wasted a couple Tempe by coming out
and going back and already white is
aiming at some weak squares in the black
position of course you know raja baath
was a very well-prepared player he you
know probably saw this line coming and
so he plays a6 actually forcing the
knight onto the d6 square where he gives
up his bishop white captures and after
f6 we kind of get a stable position why
it simply develops black simply develops
and white
goes in for this pretty forcing line
with Bishop b6 which forces black to
play Knight f5 otherwise of course the
queen is actually simply trapped queen b
for knight c6 queen c5 queen e7 so what
do you think's going on here obviously
black is still up upon but it's fair to
say that white has some compensation for
it so what compensation does white have
here it's can be kind of tough to
actually you know say it you know out
loud you know like okay I'm sure I have
compensation but but what is the
compensation where is it at how is white
justifying being down upon here what do
you think yeah this Bishop is not a good
piece it's gonna take blacks some time
to improve this piece maybe he'll have
to do you know a couple moves before it
can get to a reasonable square anything
else
yeah so some awkward development for
black this struck in this bishop both
kind of on on on uncomfortable squares
what else do you think what else are
some of White's advantages here
so one you know I'll use the word
imbalance so where the Jeremy Stillman
uses a lot 1 imbalance here and in
almost any position like this to look at
is the minor pieces so black has two
knights and one bishop and we already
said this bishops pretty bad whereas
white has two bishops in one night and
so when you get this type of thing where
one side has a bishop that the other
does not it's really important to look
at that color squares so of course the
the lifting bishop for black is this
dark squared bishop so a lot of whites
play is going to come from the dark
squares so blacks dark squares are weak
he's going to be in some trouble if he
can use his pawns to kind of control the
dark squares that's the standard way of
playing against a bishop that you don't
have use your pawns to control those
squares that you're missing Bishop
cannot so what do you think our black
Starks Square is going to be pretty well
controlled by the pawns here or there
going to be some weaknesses that white
can try to exploit to make this bishop
good or bad
it's kind of tough right and it's kind
of an unfair question to ask because it
kind of remains to be seen right right
now this bishop looks okay it's on a
pretty good score on b6 you can imagine
black would play some natural moves like
d6
maybe e5 like we said and really try to
shut this Bishop out of the game but
these are the things you should be
keeping in mind here in a position like
this I won't ask you if you think this
compensation is enough for the pawn
because obviously these are two very
high-level players the position is about
balance because they're both still in
the opening after Queen e7 do you think
the whites should trade Queens though
this is a question I do want to ask you
and if not what else can you even play
okay why is that
well yeah maybe it doesn't make sense to
move this Queen away that's a good point
there's really no squares for it to go
to these are all kind of kind of blocked
off but should he take on e7 or should
he let blacks try to take on c5 yeah
it's exactly right there's a common
phrase in chess it's sometimes it's a
punchline but a lot of times it makes a
lot of sense to take is a mistake by
taking a piece you actually just serve
to improve your opponent's pieces a lot
of the time and here it might look like
if he takes with either Knight you know
he's actually making his knight worse
but maybe taking what the King is
actually playable here for black and his
King is centralized it's now approaching
an endgame I wouldn't call it an endgame
just yet and this King is gonna be a
valuable valuable piece in the center so
instead white makes a useful move
castles Queen side now should black take
is taking a mistake here the question
goes both ways
so what are you guys kind of thinking
about when you try to answer this
question
yeah am i improving White's pieces
that's always a good question to ask
that's the the kind of the root of the
the phrase to take is a mistake it's
usually you're improving your opponent's
pieces by capturing
other things to consider is especially
in this case black has the option to
just decline this trade and that's the
option that he chooses in this case he
plays d6 and so what black is saying is
I think my queen is a more useful piece
than than your queen actually the most
common move here is to actually take
this clean off the board trading is much
more common I believe because in the
ends White's advantage is kind of an
activity right and there's this old
adage you should trade down when you're
up in material well that doesn't apply
in every position it makes some sense
here especially because a lot of whites
play comes from you know the mobility of
his pieces he can move his pieces around
attack different areas on the board
and taking off the Queens kind of
alleviate some of those threats but
instead we see d6 forcing the White
Queen back to a3 black castles and white
plays g4 tonight comes back to h6 and we
see York g1 so which player would you
prefer here white or black what do you
think all right hands up for white
- people prefer white who prefers black
for people prefer black so why do you
guys prefer the black pieces it's okay
to say that you counted the pawns and
black heads more that's that's a valid
reason less scattered that's interesting
yeah I don't know it's fair to say
White's pieces are a little bit all over
the place here and whereas black you
know pretty compact that's that's fair
to say so fair enough why did you two
prefer the white pieces is it because
you saw the one down here by the white
pieces it's also a valid reason
yeah fair enough I think this is the I'm
so did you have some of that okay all
right fair enough
supernova likes black interesting so for
people plus the YouTube chat all
preferring the black pieces I actually
prefer the white pieces here and so this
is something I've said before I think on
the show but when you try to evaluate a
position it can definitely be useful to
say okay what's going on right now
what's going on here and you say well
okay whites pieces look a little bit
scattered and blacks pieces look pretty
well you know pretty more compact
together black is currently up upon and
that's that might lead you to think that
you know maybe black is doing okay here
but more useful when you're evaluating
positions is actually to think well
what's about to happen
what are both players going to do here
we see white just made a move and so
what is black going to do what are as
next few moves going to be what is black
trying to do here
it's a valid point the d6 pawn is
hanging so is he going to fix it somehow
can you fix it somehow
so I mean you can play move like Knight
f7 right in defense so let's say black
plays the natural knight f7 now what is
this what is white going to do what are
his next few moves gonna be
he's kind of telegraphing a bit with g4
any ideas
all right I'll pick on Ryan because he's
the highest rated here what do you think
whites should be doing Ryan after Knight
f7 yeah so these ideas of f4 possibly
going for g5 possibly looking looking
for f5 all makes sense
there's also moves like 94 to look at so
really what's what's going to happen is
white and black both need to play to
improve their pieces and the question is
whose plans are actually coming through
faster whose plans are gonna make more
sense here and I think the answer to
that is actually whites plants are
coming through faster and we'll see in
the game the night f7 was actually
played and why did ahead continue with
f4 and he's already looking at things
like g5 he's looking you know at things
like 94 putting some more pressure onto
these pawns whereas black would love to
play move like 'if I've but there's a
big downside to this what's the downside
to e5 trying to open up this bishop
yes that's exactly right
it unde offends the d v square and it
makes white tonight incredibly strong
you know looking at squares like c7
already just hitting the queen looking
at squares like f6 potential sacrifices
are our own whites mind especially after
g5 so ii v not really the the best move
for black to look out for here and so
because of that white has a very
concrete plan to improve his pieces he
just wants to break open these dark
squares like I said paying attention to
that color complex of the bishop that he
has and his opponent doesn't and whereas
black doesn't seem to have a concrete
plan to improve this Bishop to improve
these rooks it's very difficult to get
these pieces out especially if he 5 is
not a good move which it isn't here and
so because of that because of what's
going to happen that's why I preferred
the white pieces and that can be really
difficult to look at from a distance but
it's all about you know finding the
ideas finding the plans and trying to
find them
pretty early on so you know you can make
these decisions pretty early on you know
do I want to go for this type of
position or do I want to go for this
other type of position which I might be
down upon here but at least I know what
I'm doing I have clear plans and I don't
know what my opponents really you know
going to be trying to do and those are
the type of positions you want to go for
the ones where you know what's going on
you know what you're doing and your
opponent has to kind of struggle to come
up with something that's really where
you can prove an advantage even at the
highest levels of chess that's that's
how they really do it
so in short I prefer white here black
continues with Bishop d7 connecting
these rooks and slightly improving this
Bishop black continues or white
continues very naturally he wants to
play g5 so he prepares it with age for
black continues with a5 now trying
desperately to find maybe some squares
for like this Knight or something or I
don't know
a 5 seems like a pretty slow move but
like I said it's very tough to come up
with moves for black here and white
wastes no time he simply plays g5
we see King h8 a preparatory move
getting off this file and now let me ask
you kind of the the critical question so
white has been you know making these
moves playing to loosen up the dark
squares so we preferred white well I
preferred white because of his plan his
plan was more clear and now that his
plan is actually happening we need to
deal with the specifics so what are the
specifics what's the best way for white
to really crack open this position what
do you think I'll give you some options
you can play a move like g6 hitting the
night in h7 can play move like h5 going
for h6 play move like G takes f you can
even play move like f5 will say or you
can play a move like 94 just bringing
more pieces in or Bishop h3 just
developing pieces these are a lot of
options the White has going on here in
his mind so what do you think which ones
do you do you prefer
it's a very tough question but I just
want to get your ideas
I'll give you a minute to think about
this one because it's not easy not easy
at all someone in the YouTube chat had
one
a couple people just want to develop the
bishop all right what are you guys
thinking the live audience what do you
think don't a single you have rookie one
yeah that's a reasonable move totally
reasonable a lot of ideas like that 95
start coming to minds the best thing to
think about here is when you're deciding
on these moves you don't really want to
say yeah well it's the best move for me
you know you do want to think about that
a little bit but more importantly you
think you have a good position it's more
important to ask well what's what can my
opponent do to get out of it what's my
opponent going to be able to do in
response
so c5 looks like a good move at first
glance you know it's taking away it's
attacking this d6 square you know really
threatening to open things up but then
the problem is well okay but my opponent
can kind of get out of things
with d5 and this is how you kind of
evaluate these moves so does anybody
like g6 you like g6 or you have a
question you like g6 so this move makes
a lot of sense but you know what is
black going to do to kind of try to save
his position here let's say he plays I
actually don't have prep on this one
let's just night h6 he just steps out of
the way how are you breaking through
all right you can take on age seven
maybe King takes give a check maybe
he'll block it it seems to be defending
and a big problem is you've left a
couple pawns behind but you're kind of
gonna get in your own way
so maybe g6 isn't best because you see
okay Knight h6
I don't see what's next for me my
opponent has a good response what about
G or G takes f any ideas of what black
might do there H five you can't really
do yet because tactically it just hangs
this pawn and so ding notice all of
these and he just made a simple
improving move I think rook e1 is a fine
move I think Bishop d3 is also a
reasonable move but his choice was to
get his piece that was further furthest
away from the action back into the game
so he played Queen b3 aiming to get this
Queen back over here and this is not the
fastest way to play and maybe not even
the best move but it's very practical
you say okay I don't think my opponents
really going to do much if he plays e5
there's always this 95 thing to look out
for I'm just gonna bring in all of my
pieces every last one into the attack AB
sanity said Queen b3 I don't know when
he said that if those seconds ago well
maybe he cheated and heard me but I'll
give him the benefit of the doubt so
shout out to him Queen b3 was the move
black plays rook c8 trying to improve
his pieces but you'll notice that these
moves actually don't seem to do a whole
lot white continues with King b1 slowly
improving his position stepping off of
this this file we see e5 finally come
from black so I've been talking a lot
about the problem with e5 problem of
course being Knight d5 but black decided
enough is enough I need to open up this
bishop no matter the cost
so he just allows Knight d5 and I think
this is actually yeah this is this is
black's big mistake so far
is a five and this is something that
happens if you have a good position and
you kind of just wait for a second a lot
of times your opponent gets tired of
sitting around and being passive and
they over commit to something this is a
fantastic way to win games without
risking much is you let your opponent
make all the mistakes you give them
enough rope to hang himself with is is
the quote and in this case that's
exactly what happens
'if I've trying to open up this bishop
but giving away this square is simply
too much this bishop comes to f5 the
King drops over to a1 the Queen comes up
to e6 and now with this knight on d5
what is the way to continue is it time
to open it up or should we bring our
pieces closer somehow
you could you absolutely could
but this night's worth more than that
rook yeah I think white would have a
very good position here after after the
fork I'm not entirely sure there's also
some tactical problems it seems like
with Knight d4 going on so I gotta look
out for some stuff but even just rook
takes e7 Bishop takes c7 this is what
black was really hoping for you know
he's getting countered play against the
white King and only at the price of an
exchange
so hey what do you think
anybody open it up or make an improving
move professor L Alex L axis left axis I
assumed once to play Bishop g2 simply
improving the pieces connecting the
rooks who likes Bishop g2 and who likes
G takes f6 opening it up I'll take a
show of hands since nobody wants to talk
G takes f6 two votes Bishop g2 zero
votes three of our class members are
undecided which is understandable this
is a very complicated position I think
white is still doing pretty well after
Bishop g2
but something has changed so earlier I
was really talking up the benefits of
playing slow improving moves waiting for
your opponent to make a mistake but in
this case your opponent has useful
things that he can do and so if you sit
around and don't do a whole lot he'll
start to be making threats of his own
with things like Knight B for aiming for
these weak light squares and so you got
to really be careful it's good to make
slow improving moves when you don't
think your opponent can do a lot but as
soon as they like you know make some
commitment where they activate some of
their pieces you really have to be on
the lookout or else they'll start
finding counter play which is what they
were hoping for so in this case I think
it's better to play quickly as ding did
with G takes f6 G takes f6 and then he
played a kind of prophylactic move which
was totally fine with a3 keeping an eye
on this troublesome Knights black
continued though with haruka b8 stepping
out of this fork finally white continued
with the natural Bishop g2 black plays
rook G it's let me see Knight e3 so
white is opened in the G file and these
light squares are now forever weak and
so white is kind of switching game plans
he's just attacking these light squares
now
we see 94 of course making a lot of
threats but luckily White has the answer
you can never use White's dark squares
because he still has this bishop and so
now was the time when Dean cashed in and
captured and we see takes takes takes
Bishop d5 and let's stop in this
position I guess and what do you think's
going on now after the complications of
mostly mostly resolves do you prefer
white still or black still or do you
prefer white now or have you switched
back and forth and then back again to
the black pieces still prefer white why
is that yeah so Black's big advantage
was the number of pawns I think that
that was fair to say and it looks like
the that extra pawn is going to fall off
the board in addition to that white
still has this advantage in activity he
has this monster Bishop sitting on a
centralized outpost this Knight does not
really make a good impression no real
future on these two squares and there's
still some tactical issues for black to
work out this Knight is hanging there's
a pin on the knight and so black has to
play some unnatural moves he has to take
and play Knight h6 and especially now
you can really see that that white's
advantage and activity gives them all
sorts of good moves here one such move
being Queen b6 really exposing how all
of blacks pawns our undefended and weak
and so white went on to pretty quickly
win this game Bishop d7 was played Queen
takes d4 after Queen e7 King a2 Knight
f5 after h5 h6 really just proving a
point that this King is going to be for
every week we see 93 and after rook III
black went ahead and resigned
of course you all see the tactical point
of rookie one what happens after 95
okay I take this he takes this with
check so you got to be a little bit
careful here thing was a little bit more
clever than that
so yeah the Queen takes up sex would be
nice if the Queen had to recapture yes
would be a nice mate
but unfortunately the night also defends
this square but it makes a good point
that these two pieces can't really leave
where they are right now
Queen g3 it's a little too much it's a
little too much so there's the oldest
rule in chess this is one I like to say
a lot when players are getting too fancy
you took your bishop you should take
them back of course the point is now you
can't capture on a1 because the Queen
was needed to defend this square and if
you move the Queen out of the way I will
take on a y8 with the same idea and so
black would just be more or less
checkmated here and the same problems
exist on this turn if you know black
passes I'll take this night and you
can't recapture do the same threat so
black resigned here and this was I think
a really well played game by white just
really showing how the activity and
pieces can be used really proving the
point that if you have a plan and your
opponent doesn't then it's going to be
very very difficult for them to play and
likely they're going to have to create
some weakness but then there was also
this moment where once black committed
to e5 activating his Bishop that was the
point where white had to kind of switch
roles you know he had this lasting
advantage with this knight on d5 now he
just had to make sure that blacks pieces
weren't going to get too active and his
plans were more important any questions
about this game any questions anything
he didn't understand it was a complex
game okay I'll talk about it quick
quickly in a recap so we had this
opening where black sacrificed time to
force white to weaken his pawn and white
simply gives up this pawn in the opening
to really increase his advantage in time
and development turn that into some
better pieces and so he cashes in here
with Knight d6 getting an advantage with
the dark squared bishop whereas black
does not have a dark squared bishop and
it's already committed to some dark
squared weaknesses he then used this
advantage to plant this Bishop on b6 and
after some more moves we realized it's
going to be kind of tough to develop
this piece as well as this rook and then
white didn't waste much time
he found his plan he wanted to expand on
the Kings side loosen up these dark
squares to improve this bishop and then
he just followed through with it very
naturally rook g1 f4 h4 g5 he brought
his last piece closer to the game and
when black overcommitted
he stepped in and proved his knight and
made sure that nothing was going on with
blacks activity kept this Knight out of
the game kept all of blacks pieces at
bay and then managed to convert very
nicely
so yeah game ended here with a
resignation so fortunately for Raja Bob
this wasn't the end of the match this
was Game two in the match I believe and
then game three was actually played I
think earlier today could have been
yesterday I might be off on that and
raja baath actually won that game so we
now have a tied match going into the
final round tomorrow so in fairness
we'll take a look at this game as well
Roger Bob chose efore rather than c4
ending responded with e5 Knight f3
knight c6 and I don't want to talk too
much about this opening because it's one
of the most common in all of chests of
course the roy Lopes and then I think at
the top level usually when grandmasters
with black want to make a draw they'll
play the Berlin in this case ding wanted
wanted to make a draw and he did
something that they used to do a lot but
don't do quite as much at the top top
level and that is play the marshal how
many of you are from issue are familiar
with the marshal gambit or marshal
attack
nobody well interesting let me introduce
it to you so white wants to play in the
center but black plays in the center
first he gets his King out of there and
then he immediately plays d5 with you oh
no preparation like c6 or anything just
goes for it in the center the downside
to this as white can capture black can
capture and after the Knight takes e5
Knight takes e5 rook takes e5 wait is
simply up upon
but of course there is compensation I'll
play a couple more moves d3 was played
in this game
d4 I think is the other main line we see
Bishop d6 rook e1 and Bishop f5 one more
move for White Queen f3 defending this
pawn defending some squares on the Kings
side and so what do you think about this
none of you are familiar with the
marshal but what do you what do you
think's going on here
where is black's compensation in this
case yeah it's really this advantage in
time he's got all of his minor pieces
develops whereas two of whites are
sitting on the back row and this Bishop
really isn't making the best impression
over here on B 3 as well as the fact
that all of white black's pieces are
kind of pointed at this Kings side and
you'll notice most of white's pieces are
not on the Kings side and that's where
he kind of generates threats generates
his attack and lastly White's extra pawn
is sitting here on d3 which is not the
most impressive square for an extra pawn
to be sitting on kind of similar to the
d6 pawn that we saw in the last game
being the extra pawn but I think this is
all still theory yet g3 is forced and
now black gets some extra compensation
in the form of weak light squares queen
h3 this should be three and what
actually gives back the pawn now in
order to develop this night when we see
the queena 5 Bishop d4 rook FD 8 a 4 h6h
for Rick ACA and this is actually
apparently a game that ding has had a
line that ding is played before with the
black pieces against Wesley so and that
one actually ended in a draw we'll see
here that Raja Bob actually deviated
from that game and the other game 8xb
was played raja baath chose Queen takes
f5 and now this game was officially
unique after Bishop takes f5 so white
has solved a lot of his problems in the
opening he developed all of his pieces
yes these light squares are a little bit
weak but the Queen's are off the board
black is not going to be checkmating
white here and all of his pieces are
developed at the cost of
losing his extra pond so what do you
think's going on now level game nothing
to worry about for either side or is one
side to be preferred what do you think
any ideas
so like I said when you're trying to
evaluate a position like this it's
always best to think about what's going
to happen rather than how things
currently are so currently I would say
black actually has a small edge and
development still these rooks are kind
of both centralized white shirts still
setting on a1 this works on a nice open
file though this night also maybe not on
the best square just yet but we see you
know black just had to recapture so it's
White's turn so what is white going to
do to improve his pieces is there a way
to improve his pieces oh yeah so a takes
b5 a very natural move and this would
actually activate the rook so we see
okay Y can activate this rook that's
good for him what can you do about this
Knight how can you activate this Knight
you could come to f3 but then I mean
what is what is the night doing on f3 it
covers a few dark squares maybe later on
it could jump into e5 there's also this
idea of Knight e4 for white right
looking at this dark square in
particular which can be pretty useful
and gaining time on the bishop so yeah I
mean night of threes not a bad move it's
it's a very natural idea so the point is
white has these moves to try to improve
his pieces a little bit whereas I would
argue maybe for black that's not quite
as easy here and we'll see that you know
white managed to actually turn this into
something I don't think black is in any
like serious danger yet I think this is
a fine position for black but it's just
noticing I would rather have the white
pieces probably because you know I know
what I'm doing you know what I can do to
improve my pieces and those are the
positions but once again I think you
should really aim for so yep professor
left axis actually also agrees wants to
play Knight e4 very nice idea ah Danny
Machuca is in the YouTube chat very
excellent video team member here at the
scene was Chess Club in the game white
actually did play 94 improving this
night hitting this Bishop black
continues with Bishop f8 and white
improves this Knight further by bringing
it to c5 and so I think the order in
which white did this is is actually
super important once again a common
phrase to take is a mistake
so if white had played eight takes b5
here activating this rook first maybe
black would take with the a pawn and
then there's the slight nuance that
after Knight c5 you are hitting air
instead of hitting an a6 pawn and so
just be on the lookout for that before
you commit to making trades and you know
think to yourself is this is actually
helping my opponent in any way and in
this case I think it would have so after
Knight c5 black has to do something
about this a6 bum comes up with a rather
tactical solution by playing night
before
if this pawn were to capture this night
of course it leaves this bishop behind
white also might try to play some
tactics like Bishop g7 you might be
thinking about but this actually leaves
behind let's see
leaves behind a lot of stuff maybe this
would be the best the best way for black
to play hitting this rook and as well as
this bishop and this wouldn't be much
for white so night before tactical
solution to his current problem so
instead of going for any of these crazy
lines white continues improving his
pieces just plays rook e5 hitting this
bishop forcing this bishop to do
something awkward or force him black to
play g6 making maybe some weaknesses in
the King white decides that the time is
right to capture on a5 on b5 now so he
takes we CC takes and now more tactics
are played with 96 which is a pretty
insane move just putting your knight on
a square where it is undefended and well
attacked by pawn so what is the point of
night II 6 first of all what if black
just ignores it what happens you know
black just moves the syrup out of the
way what was White's point
and idiots I think white can win a piece
here if not he'll get a very good
position
it is still kind of messy
what do we think
so as always you want to start with
maybe some some forcing moves look at
some captures look at some checks don't
see any checks yeah so that's a very
relevant point this work has moved off
of the attack of the bishop so this
tactic looks a little bit different of
course however we've placed our knight
onto the square where it is hanging so
maybe if we take the knight he would
take over so do what yeah I think that's
right so you could take this bishop and
then of course if black just recaptures
then we take this guy and be up a piece
either way there are some messy things
going on here with something like this
but I think Bishop d6 would be enough to
really guarantee a winning position so
black can't just ignore it so what's the
tactical point if he takes this Knight
what is white going to play
yeah that's a great point in the game
Bishop takes c6 was actually played but
if you had done this we would take this
bishop and then take this pawn but okay
Bishop takes instead the same idea
follows rook takes c6 f e6 Bishop takes
King gauge seven and now we take this
rook he takes us back and what has
happened at the end of the day White has
one upon one way or another down a piece
but you take the piece back I'm sorry
the line wasn't quite done yet so C
takes before white is up upon he has a
lot of weaknesses on the on the Queen
side though this Bishop is is really
eyeing this pawn currently and so
definitely not an easily winning
position by it by any stretch of the
imagination the next move was rook C for
hitting both of these pieces the bishop
comes to f6 black decides I want this
bishop off the board because as we all
know all Rokan games are drawn
but instead white says no I think I'll
keep this Bishop on the board and now we
see Rick see six black just defends this
pawn white plays this slightly awkward
looking rook a to just taking the slow
route defending his pawns shoring up all
its weaknesses and now I think black
really or yeah here is where I think
blacks started missing his chances to to
draw this game so black played a very
natural move black played King g8 but
the natural moves actually weren't
enough here this was actually a pretty
serious mistake for black so let you try
and figure out the improvement for black
black has to do something concrete to
make sure that white can't just build up
his position here something immediate
by immediate I don't mean like on the
next turn he does something and then
White has to like you know give up on
winning but he has to play quickly here
otherwise White will be able to
permanently improve his pieces yes and I
did want to mention Roque - is the
beginning of the immortal Machuca ruck
maneuver where you activate the rook by
bringing it to the second rank and then
moving it over
this is a tough question
well you guys come up with at least some
some kind of idea here something
concrete
so yeah it's it's black to move so we're
trying to find the way black can try to
hold this position forever but it's a
good point weight is only one move away
from putting this Bishop on a square
where it's very nicely defended and you
can imagine let's say if this bishop
let's say this line happens and Bishop
f8 you could try and shake this piece
loose still you know you saw this option
to try to shake the piece loose
someone suggested Bishop f6 pretty
natural move just trying to trade off
the bishops and this is the the crux of
the drawing idea for black is if you can
get these bishops off the board with you
know causing no further harm to your
position you should be able to draw
pretty easily the stroke endgame should
be a draw and so the question is how can
I immediately make sure these bishops
get off the board and that's what black
really kind of missed here Bishop f6
actually not quite the way to do it
because there is this nice Bishop c5
move and now if you bring your King to
the center I have this nice move b3
activating my rook and by the time you
play a move trying to shake loose my
bishop I can play this move defending
and keeping my bishop here forever
and after something like this now this
trick endgame might not be so easy to
hold it's much easier with these pawns
staying doubled so this was the
immediacy that a black mist White has
this nice idea of kind of cementing this
Bishop on c5 and so if black doesn't
play immediately for example like this
white can improve his position and make
sure that this bishop trade isn't ever
going to be very good for for black so
what black should have done is actually
Bishop e5 this is the way to force the
bishops off the board now no matter what
white does Bishop d6 comes next with a
fork and there's really no way to stop
the bishops coming off here and this
would have been the pretty nice drawing
idea I think for ding instead though we
see King g8 yeah rook a - we saw King g8
and now after Bishop c5 this Bishop is
very nicely planted here we see king f7
King G - King e6 b3 finally the the rook
sees daylight again
after h5 King f3 King f5 you see white
slowly bringing these pieces forward
rook d2 once again the immortal Machuca
rook Bishop e5 d5
and now this is a still a tough endgame
I wouldn't say white is completely
winning here but it's tough for black to
kind of make moves right this rook seems
kind of pinned in on the sixth rank
guarding these weaknesses White's pieces
are nice and active and if white or
black isn't careful this King is just
going to come in in the game King e6 was
played which just allows King e4 and
this was kind of doom for King doom for
ding after King e4 a slightly better try
might have been King f6 when I for King
f4 King e4 you could hold this bishop on
e5 for slightly longer makes some more
make it a little bit more troublesome
for this King to stay on such an
advanced square but after King e6 King
e4 Bishop f6 now white is pushing
forward shaking looseness h5 pawn and
black can't hold on to can't hold on to
everything here and we see the pieces
come over h5 will fall and these two
connected passed pawns will will win the
game and so that's how raja baath
managed to equalize the score in the
World Cup
once again final round of the standard
tomorrow if they happen to draw that
game they will move into tie breaks
which I think there's a whole
complicated series of tiebreaks they
play like two 25-minute games then two
10-minute games than two blitz games and
then an Armageddon if they're still tied
after that so that'll be definitely one
to watch unless I'm mistaken ding gets
the white pieces again tomorrow
so he'll be the one likely trying to
press trying to end this match but if
not we'll get treated to some very
interesting tie breaks on the following
day so I would be sure to check this one
out it starts tomorrow morning I think
it's pretty early our time but if you
want to set your alarms get up for it I
would highly recommend checking out
these games once again so the idea is we
were looking at today was mostly about
trying to evaluate positions and trying
to figure out our plans
and if you're doing this pretty early on
you can kind of steer the game towards a
position where you know your plan your
solid and your plan and that's like the
minimum that you want you want to be
able to figure out your plan and your
position and have something to do with
your pieces and that's what makes it so
much easier to play it if you can do it
then it's even better if you can force
your opponent into a position where it's
slightly unclear what his plan is going
to be how he's going to improve his
pieces we definitely saw more of that in
the first game but even in this game we
saw earlier on here out of the opening
you know we saw these plans for white to
improve his pieces and we saw that black
was just kind of forced to react to them
he didn't have many plans of his own
just yet and so this is how these
players are proving an advantage and you
might think that my games are decided by
tactical blunders this doesn't affect me
in any way but that's really not true
because tactical blunders often happen
when you get yourself into a worse
position where your pieces don't make
sense and so if you're playing moves
that improve your pieces make your
pieces coherent and working together
that's the best way to avoid positions
where you're falling in through these
tactics and obviously these blenders are
always going to happen but you can at
least limit them in this way by playing
you know plans that make sense
ways to improve your pieces and kind of
keeping your opponent penned in so
that's the takeaway that you can take
away from the takeaway that you can take
away from these games that are played at
such a high level you can still try to
emulate some of this in your games and
yes the results are going to be
different you're not going to start
playing like Dino ran out of nowhere but
it is still useful to learn in your
games and that's why I recommend
watching chesa at a high level it gives
you something to try and strive for try
and play it for any questions about this
game any questions about the lecture in
general tonight from youtube from from
you guys here in the audience yeah
much earlier white played d3 inside of
the
yes so I'm not gonna lie to you I don't
know all the nuances of the Marvel
attack d4 is the main line here and this
has been played you know thousands of
times and all I know is theoretically
it's supposed to be equal for black the
idea with bringing the the pawn to d3 I
think is to keep some of these squares
more under control
keep this diagonal a little bit more
closed to hamper these these light
squared plans from from black but I'm
gonna be 100% honest with you I don't
know that for sure
well yeah and the idea sometimes is to
give it away in exchange for time like
we saw this game for for white here via
the marshal is a very old very nuanced
opening it's one of the best defenses
for black against the roid Lopez and so
it's I I don't want to I don't want to
touch that and pretend I'm an expert on
it because I'm not I don't play this
with either color any other questions
all right well in that case I don't see
anything from the YouTube chat thank you
guys for joining me tonight
this has been another episode of the
road to 2000 be sure to join me next
week I will be back and we'll continue
our paths on the road thanks
you
[Music]